i am about to do something that most of
you will probably find disconcerting in
fact the first time that i saw someone
do this i too found it disconcerting
so just as a little bit of background so
far when we've been thinking about our
space axis and we've really just been
focusing on one dimension of space we've
been focusing on the x dimension or the
x prime dimension depending on whose
frame of reference we are talking about
we measure that in terms of meters
we measured that in terms of meters and
then when we thought about time well we
said well
initially we said well time is
fundamentally something different than
space so we had a different set of units
called seconds in fact you know this
goes well before we
well before the 20th century when we got
special relativity this goes all the way
back to noon and well before even that
where we said hey time is something
different we measured in units of time
in seconds or minutes or hours or days
while distance which is different than
time we measured in meters or feet or
miles or kilometers or whatever else but
as we started to get into this world of
special relativity and we started to see
that space and time are not each
absolute and in fact we can actually
think things think of all events as
happening in this continuum called space
time and i say it fast space time
because it's not saying space dash time
two different things it's saying that
they're really just different directions
in this continuum space time
and so if they're all the same thing why
do we use different units for space and
time why do we use seconds for time and
meters for space or at least in these in
the examples that i've been doing so far
and so to fix that instead of calling
this the t prime axis or the t axis
instead of labeling it in terms of
seconds what we can do and this is the
part that many of you will find
disconcerting
let's call this the c times t prime axis
and let's call this the c times t axis
and the c times t prime axis well what's
that going to do well we know that the
speed of light is an absolute it is if
we're measuring it in and i'll i'll do
approximately because it's actually 2.9
something but approximately 3 times 10
to the 8th meters per second for the
sake of all of these videos i'm just
assuming it's 3 times 10 to the 8 meters
per second for simplicity it's roughly
that
so if we were to take c times time
instead of this being one second in
terms of seconds well we multiply it
times three times 10 to the 8 meters per
second well the seconds cancel out and
we're left this if we want to measure
time in terms of meters would be 3 times
10 to the 8th meters
so this is three times 10 to the eighth
meters instead of calling it one second
this over here is negative so that over
there is negative three times ten to the
eighth meters along the c t prime axis
likewise this what we called one second
right over here instead we can call this
as three times ten to the eighth meters
this we could call negative three times
ten to the eighth meters now this will
be counterintuitive because you've
always viewed time
as fundamentally something different
than meters you haven't been thinking in
terms of space time in fact in our
normal human experience we don't
experience the world in terms of space
time time is something that we're just
falling forward into and and and space
is something that we feel like we have
more agency and we can move in the
different dimensions of space more
easily while time it just feels like
we're plummeting forward in that
dimension but now we're thinking in
terms of space time and this makes our
units the same now if it helps you you
could view this as 3 times 10 to the 8
light meters so you could think of this
as the time it would take for light to
go three times ten to the eighth meters
likewise if we wanted everything in
terms of what we traditionally conceive
of as our time dimensions we could have
kept this as one second instead of
calling this three times ten to the
eighth meters we could have called this
one light second which would be the
distance that light travels in what we
measure or what we consider to be one
second but the benefit of this is now
we're consistent we're measuring
different directions in space time which
is kind of continuum there is no
separate time and space we're measuring
them all in the same units which we will
find is very very convenient so i know
this is going to take a little bit of
time to get your head around and i'll
maybe do a few more videos to make you
feel comfortable with this type of idea
but this will be a convenient thing for
us especially as we start to view as
especially as we start to you have a
kind of
a metric in our
what we would call our minkowski
space-time
because we're going to be operating in
the different dimensions as if they have
the same units so hopefully you know i
encourage you to kind of sit and ponder
and and think about this a little bit
and hopefully it doesn't bother you too
much